j'ai reçu ma première commande avis qui
est
c'est la nouvelle mode commander des
vêtements en ligne chez le géant chinois
Chine puis publier des vidéos de ses
achats sur les réseaux sociaux comme Tik
Tok ou Instagram de la publicité
gratuite
[Musique]
stratégie qui a propulsé en quelques
années la marque Chine au premier rang
du marché de La Poste fashion la mode
rapide d'ailleurs pour femme à 27
dollars un chandail de dentelle pour 20$
une robe à 16 dollars et surtout une
collection qui se renouvelle à un rythme
aurissant plus de 1000 nouveautés chaque
jour
les concurrents comme H&M et Zara ont
emboîté le pas mais ont du mal à suivre
c'est vraiment un industrie qui est basé
sur l'offre et non la demande comme les
collections se sont accélérées le rythme
des tendances c'est aussi accéléré donc
on est toujours avec une nouvelle
proposition consommateur pour l'inciter
à acheter davantage est-ce une industrie
qui mise beaucoup sur le volume
[Musique]
le consommateur moyen achète aujourd'hui
60% plus de vêtements quand l'an 2000
mais les portes deux fois moins
longtemps une tendance qui n'est pas
sans conséquence l'industrie de la mode
et l'un des plus gros pollueurs de la
planète et génère plus d'émissions de
carbone que les transports aériens et
maritimes combinés une industrie aussi
gourmande en ressources il faut en
moyenne 2600 litres d'eau pour produire
un t-shirt
7700 pour une paire de jeans bien sûr
c'est vêtements là qu'on peut quasiment
parler de vêtement jetable il
aboutissent plus rapidement dans les
sites d'enfouissement je pense que tous
les gens ne sont pas conscients de
l'impact environnemental de la mode
en disant la proportion de textile
retrouvée dans les dépotoirs du Québec à
doubler les centres de dons des
friperies sont débordés les boutiques
Renaissance par exemple n'arrivent pas à
revendre la moitié des vêtements reçus
je reste est assemblé en ballot et la
plupart du temps envoyer à l'étranger en
Afrique par exemple pour y être liquidés
ou jeté
face aux excès du toujours plus toujours
plus vite Anne-Marie Laflamme se fait la
poutre de la Slow fashion de la mode qui
prend son temps et de la confection des
co-responsables c'est une production
manufactoriale qu'on considère zéro
déchet donc il y a pas de retail textile
qui s'envole enfouissement puis les
objets peuvent être retransformés comme
ça en nouveaux objets ensuite c'est avec
l'environnement en tête qu'elle a fondé
sa ligne de vêtements atelier B tout ici
est conçu et confectionné sur place ou à
proximité à partir de fibres naturelles
on prend en conservation l'ensemble du
cycle de vie du vêtement donc ça part
évidemment de l'approvisionnement avec
quoi on travaille nos chemises par
exemple pour les mêmes boutons depuis
plusieurs années ce qui nous permet
d'avoir jamais sur plus de production de
toujours réutiliser les garnitures
mes secrets d'eau écologiques et
éthiques à un coût une chemise se vante
ici 180 dollars un t-shirt
la créatrice espendant convaincu que
l'exemple peut être répliqué par
d'autres sur une plus grande échelle
c'est certain que nous on est une toute
petite entreprise donc on sait qu'on est
une goutte dans l'industrie mais je
pense que les idées qu'on a les
recherches qu'on fait mais peuvent faire
partie d'un mouvement aussi plus grands
peuvent montrer qu'il y a des choses qui
peuvent être fait différemment puis
inspirer d'autres entreprises aussi pour
l'implémentation dans le secteur textile
du principe pollueur-payeur une taxe ou
une loi pour imposer aux producteur de
vêtements la responsabilité de gérer la
fin de vie de leurs produits au Canada
en ce moment il y a aucune législation
il commence à avoir des des pourparlers
ne soient pas brûlés ou déchirés
mais c'est encore juste des idées
autre exemple autre modèle Annette
Guyane est une passionnée de mode mais
soucieuse d'environnement elle vivait de
plus en plus mal avec les conséquences
de ses achats
ma démarche est en réaction à la
surconsommation j'ai beaucoup de
problèmes avec le gaspillage quand j'ai
réalisé que c'était possible de
consommer de manière à respecter
l'environnement et en plus d'épargner de
l'argent pour moi ça faisait juste du
sens elle a donc fondé le choix club une
boutique de vêtements usagers aux
apparences de friperie haut de gamme
mais c'est en fait une bourse d'échange
de vêtements une grande garde-robe
collective partagée entre copines au
lieu d'être comme un club de lecture à
10-12 on est quelques centaines de
femmes à aimer les vêtements et à
vouloir échanger des vêtements c'est
différent parce que c'est vraiment plus
sympa
une fois par mois les membres s'y
retrouvent même autour d'un verre pour
se choisir des nouvelles tenues et y
laisser celle qu'elle ne porte plus ici
rien à vendre tout est échangé on amène
des trucs on prend des trucs on donne on
prend c'est vraiment la circularité
exactement ce que je recherchais une
bonne affaire pour le porte-monnaie et
une bonne action pour la planète ça fait
trois ans que je suis membre du swap
club puis pour vrai ma consommation de
vêtements dans les magasins fast fashion
à diminué déjà 85 % depuis que je viens
ici je suis au défi pendant un an en
que de la pluie acheter de nouveaux
vêtements pendant un an et puis
maintenant je l'ai adopté ça fait
vraiment partie de mon mode de vie on
achète moins mon achète mieux puis ici
mais c'est une belle façon de tester des
choses
le recyclage textile n'est à ce jour
vraiment pas au point ni rentable on
l'absence de mesure gouvernementales
pour s'attaquer aux problèmes la
solution se situe entre les mains des
consommateurs faut juste se dire ce que
c'est la robe que je cherche la paire de
chaussures que je veux avoir existent
sur le marché du second main pas besoin
de se le commander neuf limité donc les
achats impulsifs privilégiez la qualité
plutôt que la quantité et faire durée ça
garde-robe actuelle